hi nice to meet you my name is leah
well i did my
bachelor in physics and then i
i studied the biomedical engineering
my phd i did in image processing in the
tel aviv university and then i did
postdoc also in image processing
and now i work in a company called
origin ai
and
for my hobby i work one day a week at
tel aviv university at the department of
mathematics
and i'm trying to
to have some fun with my applied math
uh and i'm going to share with you uh
two works that we did at the university
uh okay so let's start
we are going to talk about a partial
differential equation
and
what i try to do
um is
to to find them the connect machine
learning with with mathematics okay so
uh let's do let's see how we can do it
so partial differential equations are
everywhere
it's in fluid mechanics in physics
it's in imaging
it's an image processing diffusion the
noising the blurring
it's also in medicine in economics
in chemistry so it's everywhere in our
life
so basically what we have the basic
structure we have some coefficient a a
and b
and the derivative with some order so
for for this example we have a
d o
d x plus b x uh the second derivative of
u with respect to x so u is for example
the image the flow
the mri image and so on
um so we defined a forward problem third
problem is defined such that
a and b the coefficients which are not
constant
practically
are known in advance and we want to find
u of x okay
and the inverse problem is the opposite
so we know u u usually is the
measurement so we have some measurements
and we are looking for the coefficients
a and b
okay i will give an example in few
minutes
uh so the question is
we studied
pda at the university and we we studied
some some methods and the question is
can we can we solve this kind of
questions
both the forward and inverse problem by
means of machine learning methods okay
this is what i'm trying to do here
okay so uh just just for notation
uh we defined some differential operator
n
which is a sum of
some coefficient a alpha and derivative
of derivative with some order m for
example we have this
l of u
l of u
equals to x d o dx plus x
in the power of 3 the second derivative
of u with respect to x
so uh
so here alpha is the alpha 1 is x the
alpha 2 is x
to the power of 3.
and
what we want to do we want to solve this
equation we want to solve l u of x
equals f of x with some domain omega and
we have some of course boundary
condition because in pde we need some
boundary condition this is what we want
to do
okay so again in the forward problem we
want to find u given the coefficient a
alpha this is the given to us
and in the inverse problem we want to
find the coefficient a alpha given the
measurement u of x
so how can we do it
uh
so i just give another example this is
the one this is a
1d example okay we have the second
derivative of u with respect to x and
this is our boundary condition so we
have a
two points where we where we have the
values
and here we have a example in 2d when we
have the laplacian of u and we have this
boundary condition it's a zero on the
boundary so this is just an example for
the setting of the pde
okay next
so usually
when the classical methods to solve
these problems
uh to use the finite elements and finite
differences so in finite element we have
the domain we
partition it into a into some
some elements usually some square some
two angles and we solve the equation for
and we have a triangle and get some
linear
linear system
in the final difference we just
approximate the derivative according to
to the definition of the of the
uh
of the of the derivative so this is very
very classical
uh the problem with these methods they
have some limitations for example
with the finite element when we have to
inverse the matrix
a lot of times it has a high condition
number so it's it can be very
problematic
again it's very very sensitive to the
distributization
okay so you see here for example
that the
the square are not fitted exactly on
this on the on the circle
a high order derivatives are very very
sensitive to noise
uh and interpolation extrapolation
values are not straightforward okay so
we have some problems with this with
these methods
so what we suggest
we suggest to
to
to solve the pde by means of a neural
network
both the forward and inverse problem
so if we are using the neural network
we can have a differential solution i'll
just show you in a few minutes how
in this setting
we
we are mesh free so we don't need to
discretize our domain
and its free form domain so we are not
restricted to the classical geometries
like square
circle and so on it can it can have some
arbitrary domain
uh and and we can easily incorporate
some prior knowledge regarding the
problem
uh
which which can
alleviate a lot of problems and can they
help with the word solution
okay so the basic idea is that we
approximate our solution by a neural
network
and how we train the network we train
the network such that
it satisfies the pde and the boundary
conditions we can think of it it's like
an unsupervised approach basically
uh
because we don't need some pairs of
x and y like in supervised the machine
learning
approach
okay so let's see how we can do it
to to to explain it i'll give a very
simple example
uh the example is the newton's law of
cooling
so what we have here we have some vessel
with some temperature for example 100
celsius and here we have the surrounding
uh the surrounding of the
of the vessel
has minus 10
degrees celsius
and the question is how the temperature
of the vessel decays over time what is
the formula
so uh
okay so we call this t t is the
temperature of the vessel uh as a
function of time and m is the
is the
temperature of the surrounding
okay so what we know from newton's law
is that the derivative of the
temperature with respect to time is
proportional to
m minus t where k is some constant
regarding the
the material the environment and so on
okay so here we have the boundary
condition so we know that at
t equals zero the temperature is 100 and
we know m and we know k for example k is
like a
0.25
and this is the analytical solution we
know that the the temperature decays in
an exp in an exponential fashion
okay this is the the analytic solution
so how do we solve it with the network
so here on the left we can see the
equation
and what we are doing we just move the k
a minus t to the left to the left hand
side so we want the left hand side to be
equal to zero
okay now we define the very simple
architecture of network so the input of
the to the network is t is the time we
have some one layer
a perceptron very simple one layer with
the 30 neurons and the output is the
temperature
okay so now what we want we want
this
equation to be satisfied for every t for
every time
so we define a loss function so this is
the loss function the the the
the left term is actually the l to norm
of the of what we want
of this
this setter
and the second
term
is basically the boundary condition so
we have like constraint optimization
regarding the the temperature okay so we
have two terms in the loss function
and what's nice here because because we
have a differential
er
er
representation of the of the the
temperature because we
will formulate as a network so we have
the close formula for t
this is of course differential if we
take a
a
smooth activation function like
hyperbolic tangent or sinusoid not value
for example
like a smooth activation so everything
is differentiable so this is the
derivative of the temperature with
respect to time and the tensorflow or pi
torch
can use the automatic differential
differentiation
so basically to do this we need only
four four lines of of uh tensorflow so
this is the loss function we have tf dot
gradients which calculates this
derivative of the temperature with
respect to time and we have this
definition of the loss that's all and we
train this network so we sample
we sample t the time
around some range we add the boundary
condition and we train the network with
this laws
okay and converge very very fast with
very very simple architecture and here
we can see the results so the blue line
is the analytical solution and the green
the green x is the estimated this is
what the network gave
okay so this is the basic idea
okay so again
we define very very simple architecture
why because we're dealing with physical
problems so it's not like cnn and the
and the complex architecture for image
classification and so on
but we use mlp very very simple mlp with
the few layers and the
hyperbolic tangent like activation and
and this is enough
to solve physical problem
okay
so the input to the network is x1 x2 it
depends on the dimension of the problem
and the output is u of x
so again this is the analytical
formulation of the network and this is
the activation
and of course we can we can derive it as
much as we can because everything is
differentiable
okay so
how do we train it what we are doing we
don't discretize as we said before we
just take
point cloud i mean the pound cloud
represents
a samples in our domain okay these are
the blue points and the red points
stands for the boundary for the for the
boundary points
so what we can do
we just
uh train the network
with mini batches where the mini batches
contain these blue
dots which are inside the domain and
they were the dots that
represent the boundary
okay so because we have don't
don't discretize
this shape is not limited to to circle
or to square or to something like that
it can be arbitrary because we just
throw points in our domain so that's why
we are not limited to specific geometry
you may get of course
of course we sample the points inside
the domain but what i'm saying that the
domain can have arbitrary shape this is
what i meant of course you're right
um okay so so
we defined the general loss function
like like we said before so we want to
solve l u equals f with the boundary
condition so this is this is our loss
function so here what we said before
this is the l to norm
uh
this is the l2 norm of lu minus f like
we saw before
and here
we added we added another term which is
the l infinity term of of this
difference
what it means is that
we don't want to reduce the loss
function in every edge l2 means
we reduces in average but we want to
reduce
also the the largest deviation so the l
infinity says that we want to minimize
the largest error that we possibly have
so it gives a lot of advantage
advantages
okay the
third term is the boundary condition
here here we can add some regularization
and exactly the same the same formula
it's also for the inverse problem it's
it's exactly the same so we have the l2
fidelity and infinity the boundary
condition and we can we can tailor our
virtualization according to our problem
okay so this is the basic framework
uh so this is the new idea that we had
and this is
also our contribution
okay so for example we can we can see an
application which is real with the which
is called eit electrical impedance
tomography where the
current is applied
on electrodes on the surface of the body
and the
the voltage is measured and the idea is
to
by by knowing the
the current and the voltage that we
measure we can infer
the sigma i mean the the properties of
the body okay this is some
this is some imaging
technique
and
i don't get into the details but
but this uh satisfies some equation so
the relation between the current the
sigma sigma is the conductivity or
density of the tissues of the body
tissues and the electrical voltage is
formalized by this
by this equation we don't get into it
i just want to say that once we have
this equation we can use our neural
network to find u and sigma okay
so
okay
so i i just
do it in steps so in the first step we
solve the forward problem it means that
we know we assume that we know sigma the
conductivity and we want to find u the
voltage okay so this is the fourth
problem this is what we calculate this
is the
this is the
the equation and we do we do exactly
what we we talked before
and here we can see some results so this
is the current
usually it's like a sinus sinus
recurrent and this is the ground tool
sigma
it's like a lung in the heart some kind
of approximation
um
and here we can see the ground truth the
grant was the solution of the of the
equation that i showed you before
to to this scenario is given here so
here i solved it with the finite element
method uh
which
with the with the tools i solved it in
matlab but it's it's also another
platform uh so this is the ground truth
of u of the potential and this is the
derivative of u with respect to x so
here we can see the derivative the shape
of this sigma and here we can see the
the results of the neural network so uh
you see that it's it's very similar to
the to the tool we have got the psnr and
mse
and it runs like 12
12 minutes on this laptop i mean not gpu
not nothing i mean it's very very fast
because also because the network is very
very simple the architecture is simple
it's not
computationally expensive
i don't remember i think it's also very
quickly
it's also very quickly
okay so when i compare it with other
method with the
method that was uh published in 2017
this method used only the l to know not
the l infinity no so you can see that we
have some artifacts with this with this
method so the l infinity gives a lot of
contribution
uh
here we we plot some histogram of the
error
uh by
by our method and the
in the previous method which didn't use
the l infinity norm and you can see that
that
the dgm method has more more errors so
the histogram in the higher errors is
more
uh include more points than us
so this is very
important
observation
next
what we did is the opposite now we solve
the the inverse problem so we have some
measurements on u and now we want to
find sigma okay so we know u and we want
to find sigma so we do exactly the same
but here we used several measurements
because we have
a common sigma for different measurement
it's like an ensemble of measurements
okay we're using some measurement
together
and again we are using the same formula
exactly the same
i do the same idea i just add some
regularization about sigma because we
have some prior knowledge that sigma is
constant
and since it's piecewise constant we can
have this
regularization lpnom
it's like a constraint on the behavior
of sigma
okay so we can add it very very
easily and the
tensorflow pie chart can derive it
very very easily
okay so this is the result this is the
ground truth okay we have two sigma
and this is our results okay this is the
reconstruction you can see good msc and
psnr in both cases
the last
just a minute and here we used arbitrary
domain okay so
we said that we're not restricted to
to classical geometries and we can use
also arbitrary domain and the the
software is
so it doesn't care i mean it's invariant
to to this shape
and here we can see again the the
inverse problem and we can you can we
can find sigma exactly the same nothing
nothing was changed the software is
exactly the same
okay so to summarize this part
we used very very simple network like
four layers with the
26 neurons we use the hyperbolic tangent
for activation
uh
i used the tensorflow with adam now we
moved to python but this is ideal
tensorflow
12 minutes
uh i use the 8 8k
points to to sample points in the domain
and the 1k points on the boundary and i
have some hyper parameter which was how
did you sample the points randomly
randomly i just want a randomly sample
inside this the seal but the points are
given
no i just can i can i can sample it
whatever i care i want because it's
unsupervised i don't i don't pay
anything for this i just sample points
and that's it
so here we um
we solved the full tomography
the full tomography says that we know
the you not in the whole domain but only
on the boundary because when we measure
on people we have the measurement only
on the surface and not inside the body
okay so this is more challenging because
we know you only on the boundary and we
know to reconstruct sigma and you inside
inside the whole domain
okay so uh what i did here i just train
i i just trained eight networks okay
eight network for you and not one
network for sigma
and then
we use alternate minimization it means
that we find u
a given sigma and then we get given near
you we find sigma and vice versa and we
do it alternately this was a more this
was more expensive because we trained
eight
uh we trained nine networks
simultaneously so here i used some gpu
but it was not very very expensive
so here we can see the
here we can see the results
so
the left column is the ground truth this
is the the proposed
without method this is the
reconstruction and here i compare to two
other methods
um okay since i don't have enough time i
just say very very briefly that
this approach is also a good
for
to solve even value problem it means
that we want to find the eagen function
of some differential operator okay so i
just do it very very briefly so we want
to to to find the eager value and eagle
function of some operator so l is the
sum differential operator this is the
eager function and this is the
eigenvalue and
again in the same in the same setting
we we
we define this loss function
and for example for this
for this case you um
second derivative of u plus
a for example for you we know that
the solution is sinus okay and
here we can see that after a few
iterations it converges into cmos
i don't have time to get more i just say
that
okay i will skip this
i just say that we can we can do it
also when we when we want multiple egan
function together we want multiple and
and we can impose some orthogonality
constraint of the hidden functions
and we can we also did it in two
dimensions so
here we can see the sinus
we we find simultaneously four egon
functions
together again this is the architecture
and the output is the four eigen
functions
and we also had it for a five five
engine function here we can see the the
results which are very close to the
ground truth
and here we can see the results in two
dimensions
so here we can see the
the eagle function of a laplacian in two
dimensions so we see this this sinus in
two dimensions
uh and lastly we did it also in the l
shape so where we see that
we compare it to the to finite element
method
okay we have some also some theories
some convergence results but i didn't i
don't talk about it here uh so to
conclude the
deep learning can be very helpful in the
solution of pde for example if if we
have more dimensions the more complex
shapes and so on
we used it for tomography for eager
problem and it can be a valid
it can be valid for more much more
problem uh
we can add some regularization some
prior knowledge it's free from domain
and it can be easily extended to a
non-linear problem a more dimensional
problem
uh and about sampling we can use some
more clever sampling not just uniform
but uh to find exactly how to sample
this is the another opening question
that we keep in the condition that the
problem is example
that you can either sample the x and you
works
yeah but we can sample it more cleverly
for example according to the gradients
and according to other criteria
okay so this is an active
research that we continue or if someone
is interested
so please
let me know yes
one one word that you emphasize is
unsupervised yeah but you're training
something so how can this
once again this is what something like
this is supervised
you know what you're training and
supervised
yeah because in so in classical
unsupervised you need pair you need x
and y you need the
a feature and you need label but
in supervised no way i think
the
right
thing is sensitive
it's not it's not the classical
self-supervise when we learn some
feature it's a
yeah you can think of it like a label
zero okay so so the label is zero but
it's it's for free we don't have to
prepare the data we don't have to
prepare it we just need to sample and
then say okay you you want the pda to be
satisfied on this point you don't need
to prepare some ground truth
okay so this is the the point
no we don't need label i mean
yeah i mean the label is like zero
because you want something equal zero so
it's not supervised in this in the in
the classical sense
okay you we we just want the equation to
be satisfied at this point so so in this
sense it's unsupervised
you have to
yeah good question good question when
the boundary condition will change we
need to train again
but now now i'm working about
a framework that will be more general
that we can give to the input value
condition very good question
did you face a vanishing
problem
vanishing vanishing gradient problem
if we
if we had which type of activation do
you use a hyperbolic tangent and
siren
silence iron is like a sinus
in the activation and you didn't face
like exploding gradients or
we had some i mean it took so a while to
converge but we did some learning
some learning ways some optimization but
it was very uh
not not something special like the
classical things the regular things yeah
if you incorporate
the transit
like sources or syncs
inside the function
let's say you have a source of a current
that's not the constant
we can formalize it i mean we can take a
problem formalize it and then and yes i
mean
actually it's very flexible so every pde
we can formalize and
and the
and declare the
the loss function
yes
yes
okay so i have some reference if someone
is interested
um did you check uh
taking only the l infinity norm and not
the l2 well it will not i mean l
infinity takes only top k largest error
so it's not enough we need we need the
whole
information in the domain okay
all right okay thank you very much
[Applause]